all right welcome welcome we are live
and waiting for president Donald Trump
to give his 2019 State of the Union
address of course delayed a week because
of the government shutdown and because
Nancy Pelosi stood her ground and said
you're just not gonna do it and that's
it and she was right
it didn't happen last week it's
happening tonight I will wait a moment
for people to connect and get on the
stream we still have about roughly 15
minutes until we are expecting Donald
Trump to start and that gives us time to
discuss what we might expect to hear
from viewers and to do a whole bunch of
other stuff so I will sort of give you
my what I will be looking for list
momentarily but first I just want to
give time for people to get connected we
will otherwise run this like a normal
stream I'll take super chats up until
Trump starts and then we'll watch the
speech together I will chime in every
once in a while if I have something to
say and then we might open the phone
lines if we get 10 new members by the
time the State of the Union address is
over we will go to the phone lines at 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 and hear what people
think about the State of the Union
address about really anything but that
will be later on in the evening so what
what I'm going to be sort of tracking
during tonight's State of the Union
address there's gonna be four or five
different things that I will be looking
at number one I'm gonna be paying
attention to policy proposals and State
of the Union addresses you know we we
tend to hear general policy ideas and
claims from presidents like if you put
this bill on my desk I will sign it and
then not super frequently do those State
of the Union statements actually make it
into legislation as such so it'll be
interesting to see number one are there
policy ideas from Donald Trump either
vague or specific either broad or
precise and I'll be taking a look at
what those are and keeping track of
those I am because it is Donald Trump
going to be
paying attention to how much of the
speech is about him we know that there
are as always going to be some guests in
the house chamber who are going to be
signaled at certain points and we are
going to be sort of evaluating who it is
that Donald Trump thinks worthy of
recognition but also how much of the
speech is about himself how much of it
is touting accomplishments and
importantly how many of those
accomplishments are actually verifiable
versus how many are demonstrably false
so we will be fact-checking
the claims that Donald Trump makes
whether it's about his economic record
and the economy whether it is about the
border wall and immigration
I read that unity is a big focus of
tonight's speech which is of course
Trump's not particularly well positioned
to call for that I think is the the the
primary point given that he has been one
of the most divisive presidents that
we've had in a very long time so we will
look at that
I am also so I'll pay attention to the
number of demonstrable lies is the force
for things we've got policies how much
of it is about Trump how much of what
kind of claims does he make about his
administration the number of
demonstrable lies and I am going to be
paying attention to Trump's delivery my
expectation is that this is not going to
be a particularly long State of the
Union address and I say that for two
reasons number one Trump's last State of
the Union address was not very long it
was one of the shortest actually if I
I'm going by memory but one of the
shortest in a very long time so in
general I don't think Trump is
predisposed to speak a long time could
that be because he has trouble reading
could that be because he doesn't like
giving speeches whatever the reason his
trend seems to be a trend with one one
data point so far at least State of the
Union is not to go too long but there
are questions about cognitive decline
right I mean there was the weird what
was referred to as the dentures in
incident about shrew Salam and god bless
that entire thing which we were told he
doesn't wear dentures so we've still not
gotten a really great explanation for
that we've seen more and more of the
sort of slowed language and repetition
of the same adjectives over and over
again so I
we'll be watching also the delivery call
me crazy but I'm gonna be paying
attention to that and seeing what we
notice does Trump seem confused up there
more more than usual given that he's
talking about things he knows very very
little about so those are the things
that I am going to be paying attention
to and I'm glad that you will be here
watching the stream watching the speech
with me my plan is to pick up the c-span
stream although I'm a little worried
because this says c-span radio app and
like a tiny part of me wonders if this
is only going to be an audio stream so
if someone is around who either has the
like what is definitely the c-span video
stream that would be great
I want to get one that will show us
everything that goes on right before the
speech starts as well and I don't know
if the White House feed will do that but
anyway if people paste whatever you
think the best stream is I don't want to
pick up like the NBC one or something
like that but if people want to link me
to whatever you think is the best stream
I will definitely put that up I'll keep
an eye on the chat for for a few minutes
here I will mention just to get
everybody on the same page before we get
started here this is actually a live
stream and we are waiting about ten
minutes away from Donald Trump's 2019
State of the Union address you can use
super chat that's the dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window to ask
questions and to send comments and I
will read those and react to those and
you can send them now there's a bunch of
stacked up which I will mention and then
we will we will get to more after the
State of the Union address if you sign
up for membership during the stream if
we get ten new members I'll open up
phone lines after we're done whenever I
open up the phone lines it does cost us
money we pay for that so if we get 10
new members I will open up the phone
lines right after the State of the Union
address is done it was my birthday over
the weekend it was my 35th birthday
shocking to many many people for
different reasons
and we sent out a big membership promo
the code is saved 35
if you apply the code SAVE 35 to the $60
per year membership on our website
you'll get a membership for just 25
bucks okay and that's a great way to get
us to those 10 members that will then
get us to open the phone lines when we
are done
please don't troll the live chat it's
really annoying and you can also now
become a YouTube channel member using
the join button underneath the video
window
so that's what's going on so let's make
a decision together as to which stream
tell I I'm on the c-span stream and I
believe that this is a great stream for
us I'm just a little bit concerned
because it says c-span radio app and
like I'm I have a 5% concern that this
is audio only so maybe if people want to
tell me a different stream I would be
glad to pull it up I'll take a quick
look here and then I'm going to get to
the I'm going to get to the super chat
so the White House now has a stream let
me see what that's looking like it's
just blank right now but we could go
with this if people prefer um yeah I
think we'll just stick with that one
let's just stick with that one I think
that that will do us that that will do
us good
and let me get now to some of the super
chats before we get started with all of
the other stuff again about 8 minutes
away from the speech let's see here
Michael McKean Tosh or McIntosh with a
dollar super chat thank you Jackson says
ever consider going on Destiny's stream
I've been listening to him a lot lately
smart guy very different style than
yours he went on Jesse Lee Peterson
amazing
yeah I think have I been on I guess he's
been on my stream a couple of times I've
not been on his stream before but he's
been on my show before and big fan big
fan of destiny would be glad to go back
on with him anytime a Vladimir Putin
sends a to New Zealand dollar super chat
it's the state of the ginyan with David
Pakman very very good all right and we
will ban that user hope that was worth
the two New Zealand Dollars for you
Eddie
XG says
why are progressives so against the
public option it's not the progressives
are against the public option
it's that progressives I think are
recognizing that this is too early to be
compromising on Medicare for all and so
if candidates are already softening to
what is the de facto Democratic platform
position sort of a bit of a red flag as
to how hard they will negotiate if they
were president Jackson says I probably
should have done research before asking
about destiny silly of me question do
you think it's worth debating with
people who argue in bad faith seems like
accepting defeat to walk away so there's
two answers it's worth debating people
who are arguing in bad faith if it's
just for fun if you're actually trying
to make progress and bring people to
your side it's it's basically a waste of
time crab 90 says David do you think the
State of the Union is necessary is it a
primary method of communication between
the president and the public or more of
a way to idolize the president in a
collective way I don't think the state
of the union is necessary but it
actually is a it gets ratings in the
sense that people do generally speaking
want to see what the president says and
with such low engagement in the United
States and 50 percent voter turnout I I
do think it is a good thing art Flores
says this may appear as a simple
question but it merits quite a hefty
response who are you more disappointed
with Trump or the people who voted for
him I'm more disappointed with the
people who voted for him in the sense
that we knew what Trump was was going to
do there was really no question about
that it's it's unfortunate that so many
people fell for it and voted for him so
I think I'm definitely more disappointed
with the people who voted for him yeah
I'm pretty clear about that let me see I
can see that some of the images here
some of these super chats are not fully
on-screen let's see if I can expand them
a bit there we go I think that helps us
okay Sean geese or guys says if Bernie
doesn't end up running would Elizabeth
Warren selecting Bernie as VP be the
next best thing we shouldn't even be
thinking about VP right now
I think Shawn let's focus on who is
going to be the candidate and then we
can talk about VP and I'm not playing
coy in any way I just haven't thought
about it I just haven't given any
thought about it and any thought I have
not thought about it in any way up until
this point in time because there is so
much more that needs to be figured out
before then okay as I mentioned if we
get 10 new members during the stream we
will open up the phone lines right after
Donald Trump is done delivering his
State of the Union address I want to say
thanks to John Bednarz who has signed up
at david pakman.com slash membership I
want to say thank you to Shawn guy soar
geese who just sent a super chat and
also is a new member and I want to say
thank you to Levi Fisher who has just
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership you might have heard me say
it was my birthday over the weekend we
did a big email blast over the weekend
telling people that because it's my
birthday why not write because it was my
35th birthday the code saved 35 on our
website drops a $60 membership to just
$25 it saves you $35 so if you go to WWE
and pac-man calm you select a $60 per
year membership and that's a really
important thing you got a switch to
yearly and then hit sign up you put in
the coupon code not vote soon 18 we've
got big bigger and better things you put
in the coupon code save 35 it'll drop
that $60 membership to just 25 bucks you
can keep that rate for as long as you
want and if we get 10 of those I'll open
up the phone lines when we are done with
the stream and I have a feeling people I
have a feeling this state of the union
address is going to be absolutely
bonkers so I encourage you to sign up
you will get a thank you from me and we
will also open up the phone lines when
Donald Trump is done speaking super
chats still in play and we're about
three minutes away at this point from
Donald Trump speaking
or at least coming in let me take a
quick look here at what's going on in
the regular chat a lot of swearing a lot
of anti-semitism as usual a lot of happy
birthdays thank you I appreciate that
people asking if I think coding should
be incorporated into public education
why not write I like it who's going to
have a better stream door cedar or
Pakman that is a great question I
wouldn't know because I'll just be doing
be doing this stream people suggesting I
go to the PBS live stream yeah let me
see if I can find that I'm glad to pick
up the PBS stream if I'm able to find it
I'm seeing USA Today the White House
c-span I'm having trouble finding the
PBS live stream let's see PBS State of
the Union I'm glad to use that one it
seems like the one people want okay here
it is we got it perfect and we have
audio are prepared very good so the
cabinet is coming in let me get our
volume set right so everybody's
comfortable with what we've got going on
all right so the cabinet is entering he
see Stephen maneechan
who is already involved in trying to
prevent the release of dominant taxes to
the House Democrats we see the whole
bumper code that people how depressing
is discounted oh god now critical if
there is anyone who makes me have a
horrible taste in my mouth it's Matthew
Whitaker we're assuming there is
minuchin with a very weird anybody see
that weird neck then kind of like the
chicken goblin or a pigeon very very odd
Pompeyo we see there's Ben Carson
reports are he may be on stimulants to
not sleep through this thing I believed
that that is Mitch McConnell's wife
Elaine Chao quite a cast of characters
here huh
there's whitaker sweaty and red as usual
I will be watching for lies I will be
watching for policy proposals I will be
watching for Trump's demeanor and
delivery and signs of cognitive decline
this program was made possible by
viewers like you
Barrett thank you who's excited let me
turn this down a little bit there are a
few other super checks that I want to
get to just while we're waiting all
right we'll turn down while while we are
waiting here black wave 54 sent to super
chat saying year was poppin Gang Gang
yes absolutely that's exactly my
sentiment as we await Donald Trump here
continuing his demand for a wall on the
u.s. southern border with Mexico
tonight's address was delayed a week by
the federal government shut down
all right so still just a lot of a lot
of waiting around going on here we see
Nancy Pelosi we see Mike Pence we see a
lot of people in the chat I don't know
if we want to hear what's going on right
now
behind mr. Trump it is his first address
before this divided Congress with a new
Democratic Nancy Pelosi just looks
thrilled doesn't she
capital and yummy al sindoor is at the
White House think I'll leave the level
president just control it in a different
spot okay so we are made it waiting will
Donald for Donald Trump a lot of people
in the chat suggesting that Trump will
be deliberately late just in order to
get attention I guess we will see
Brandon Roach asks via super chat can I
upgrade my monthly membership to a
yearly yes you can I recommend you
cancel the monthly first and then just
set up a yearly no reason to complicate
things but there is an upgrade function
no problem whatsoever let me say thank
you to Shawn Moultrie and Jonathan
paddock or
who have signed up for new memberships
at david pakman.com slash membership
using the coupon code safe 35 safe 35
bucks because I turned 35 over the
weekend that's it it's super easy $25
for a $60 membership kit as long as you
want five of ten if we get to 10 new
members during the State of the Union
live stream I will open up the phone
lines wide open after the speech
the more new members we get the longer I
will keep the phone lines open because
it does cost us money to go to the
phones as as they say these days waiting
for Donald Trump here Judy Woodruff
asking some questions Paul Flores has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership I appreciate that very very
much thank you to everybody wishing me a
happy birthday people suggesting
drinking games every time that Donald
Trump sniffs and let's now go to the
House of Representatives and see what is
going on there just a second just one
second yes technically that's true
and the president enter is the chamber
of the House of Representatives Lisa I
interrupted you there that we could hear
the president announcing his oranges
arms but continue with what you were
saying you were saying a lot of anxiety
there well I'm happy to be interrupted
by this term the present-day United
States outside
[Applause]
in general the last year has been one of
ups and downs legislatively however
there's a lot of excitement because
think about this 101 people in that
chamber are newly elected they've never
been to a state of it alright so Donald
Trump making his way in the most
important things I will be paying
attention to here what policy ideas do
we hear from Donald Trump how much of
this entire thing is merely about him
how many lies does he tell during this
thing what accomplishments does he claim
for his administration during this
speech and does he seem confused his are
the concerns about cognitive decline
real are they overblown does he seem
uncomfortable does he seem to be having
trouble reading and all of that stuff so
we will see his tie already sort of
off-kilter they're not sure how that
happened maybe somebody will correct it
for him it would be funny if it stayed
that way the entire time but unclear
that that is going to happen Donald
Trump continuing to make his way towards
the lectern there is Supreme Court
justice Chief Justice John Roberts
continuing to approach amid applause I
mean quite literally applause everybody
applauding so far always interesting to
see when there is bipartisan applause
and when there is only partisan applause
Donald Trump continuing to approach will
anyone sleep during this thing
ben Carson always a top candidate but
unclear we don't know all right and
there is Donald Trump now approaching
the moment we've all been waiting for
and reading from will ceremonially hand
copies of his speech to the vice
president Mike Pence and to Nancy Pelosi
who looks utterly disgusted with
President Donald Trump
the president at this point enjoying
round of applause yes as he often does
and clapping himself as well on Ian's
trumpet standing it's a point of Honor
as the president I see Jared the golden
girl watch this president before he
seems to be enjoying another well as he
does the center of attention and mark
the attention so she sits for in the
speech is his aides are saying that this
is going to be an effort to unify the
country
yeah that's realistic the most divisive
president wisest person his entire
presidency has been based on division
and acrimony in anger and probably his
second round of planning so that they
mean Walter that that's the skepticism
that's out there isn't it it's the
skepticism but look there are actually
real things on the table here that have
to be this theoretically have to be
figured out in the next few days here
especially about mr. vice president
members of Congress the first lady of
the united states a part of the cake
lady b15 kind of a job with what we
don't know
she's definitely the first lady that
seems very very good
members of Congress and my first lady of
the United States
[Music]
as we begin
I stand here ready to work with you to
achieve historic breakthroughs for all
Americans millions of our fellow
citizens are watching us now gathered
and my fellow Americans hoping that we
will tolerate at a moment of not as 200
people hearing some kind of a very
strange I know
the agenda I will lay out this evening
is not a Republican agenda or a Democrat
agenda
it's the agenda of the American people
many of us have campaigned on the same
core promises to defend American jobs
and demand fair trade for American
workers to rebuild and revitalize our
nation's infrastructure to reduce the
price of health care and prescription
drugs to create an immigration system
that is safe lawful modern and secure
and to pursue a foreign policy that puts
America's interest first that's a new
opportunity in American politics if only
we have the courage together to seize it
confusion what if you mean by courage
what is he talking about
victory is not winning for our party
victory is winning for our country
go on
this year America will recognize two
important anniversaries that show us the
majesty of America's mission and the
power of American pride in June we
marked 75 years since the start of what
General Dwight D Eisenhower called the
Great Crusade the Allied liberation of
Europe in World War two I'm curious
where he's going with this
on d-day June 6 1944 15,000 young
American men jumped from the sky and
60,000 more stormed in from the sea to
save our civilization from tyranny here
with us tonight are three of those
incredible heroes going right through
this usually they do the first class
Joseph Reilly
Staff Sergeant Irving Locker and
Sergeant Herman zhichen
it is interesting to go to this so early
in the ski we usually fear this further
in in this order
approaching the climax in game you want
the Trump going with this maybe strategy
to try to get more of the early audience
on his side possibly but it is
interesting to see him go to this
portion so early in the evening
[Applause]
gentlemen we salute you in 2019 we also
celebrate 50 years since brave young
pilots flew a quarter of a million miles
through space to plant the American flag
on the face of the moon half a century
later we are joined by one of the Apollo
11 astronauts who planted that flag buzz
okay this is a very very cheap stunt
this is an extraordinarily cheap stunt
Trump who doesn't even want to fund NASA
opens by just pointing to an astronaut
pathetic honestly love buzz aldrin the
visit for better
Thank You buzz
this year American astronauts will go
back to space on American Rockets
in the twentieth century America saved
freedom transform science redefined the
middle class and when you get down to it
there's nothing anywhere in the world
that can compete with America
extraordinary
from so far I mean this is so we're what
seven minutes in and so far we've had oh
and there's a kindness phone does not
seem into it he pointed to astronauts
and vets and said America's great the
next chapter of this great American
adventure and we must create a new
standard of living for the 21st century
tell us how an amazing quality of life
for all of our citizens is within reach
we can make our community safer our
families stronger our culture richer our
faith deeper and our middle class bigger
and more prosperous than ever before
saying that it can be done doesn't tell
us how or suggest you're gonna be the
one to do it
sit down Jared give me a break but we
must reject the politics of revenge
resistance and retribution and embrace
the boundless potential of cooperation
compromise and the common good
together we can break decades of
political stalemate we can bridge all
divisions heal old wounds build new
coalition's forge new solutions and
unlock the extraordinary promise of
America's future the decision is ours to
make we must choose between greatness or
gridlock results or resistance vision or
vengeance incredible progress or
pointless destruction tonight I ask you
to choose greatness that would mean
Bodie be our
so far this is one of the most vapid and
Hollow State of the Union addresses I
can remember over the last two years my
administration has moved with urgency
here we got historic speed to confront
problems neglected by leaders of both
parties over many decades in just over
two years since the election right we
have launched an unprecedented economic
boom a boom that has rarely been seen
before there's been nothing like it we
have created 5.3 million or nothing like
it and importantly added 600,000 new
manufacturing jobs something which
almost everyone said was impossible to
do but the fact is we are just getting
started
[Applause]
wages are rising at the fastest pace in
decades and growing for blue-collar
workers who I promised to fight for
they're growing faster than anyone else
thought possible blue-collar million
Americans have been lifted off food
stamps they were all offering to cut
down
the US economy is growing almost twice
as fast today as when I took office and
we are literally under considered far
away the hottest economy anywhere in the
world not even close now that's
ridiculous
unemployment has reached the lowest rate
in over half a century
african-american Hispanic American we
were waiting for Asian American
unemployment have all reached their
lowest levels ever recorded
unemployment for Americans with
disabilities has also reached an
all-time low
I like pens pretending to care about
them
people are working now than at any time
in the history of our country 157 yes
and more people are also not working now
than at any other time because the
population keeps growing
we passed a massive tax cut for working
families and doubled the child tax
credit that's true they did go to the
pack
we virtually ended the estate tax or
death tax as it is often called on small
businesses for ranches and also for
family farms yeah hand out to rich
people doubled the exemption from
Florida half-million from from 5.45 mama
care individual mandate penalty
and to give critically ill patients
access to life-saving cures we passed
very importantly right to try
my administration has cut more
regulations in a short period of time
not true any other administration
there's the entire tenure demonstrative
false and meaningless even true
companies are coming back to our country
in large numbers thanks to our historic
reductions in taxes and regulations not
true and it's simply no evidence and we
have unleashed a revolution in American
energy the United States is now the
number one producer of oil and natural
gas anywhere in that's bad and he's
trying to reinvigorate coal coal the
world is laughing at us on the issue of
energy
and now for the first time in 65 years
we are a net exporter of energy easy for
me
after 24 months of rapid progress our
economy is the envy of the world our
military is the most powerful on earth
by far and America
the Beckham mouth should we be clapping
at this oh my god that depends who is
his beard get the kids out of the room
Wow
America is again winning each and every
day members of Congress the state of our
union is strong brings quite hollow
Nancy Pelosi shaking her head down
keep looking up to the left that's my
line
[Applause]
that sounds so good almost as good as
people saying this country is vibrant
and our economy is thriving like never
before when Friday it was announced that
we added another three hundred and four
thousand jobs last month alone almost
double the number expected that's true
he did he did finally say something
that's true
an economic miracle is taking place in
the United States and the only thing
that can stop it are foolish Wars
politics or ridiculous partisan
investigations
Oh Nancy Pelosi looks disgusted as she
should be
an Adam Schiff that was a lot about
what's going to be happening soon
if there is going to be peace and
legislation there cannot be war and
investigation the president is using the
State of the Union to demand an end to a
supposedly independent legal
investigation be United at home to
defeat our adversaries abroad this new
era of cooperation can start with
finally confirming the more than 300
highly qualified nominees who are still
stuck in the Senate in some cases years
and years waiting not right sort of like
America Ireland
the Senators failed to act on these
nominations which is unfair to the
nominees and very unfair to our country
I agree let's get married guards at the
time for bipartisan action believe it or
not we have already proven that that's
possible in the last Congress both
parties came together to pass
unprecedented legislation to confront
the opioid crisis a sweeping new farm
bill historic VA reforms and after four
decades of rejection we passed VA
accountability so that we can finally
terminate those who mistreat our
wonderful veterans
[Applause]
I don't know what other people think but
I'm I'm sensing way more partisan
applause versus bipartisan than than in
most of these speeches just weeks ago
both parties United for groundbreaking
criminal justice reform they said it
couldn't be done they do
last year I heard through friends the
story of Alice Johnson people told I was
deeply moved in 1997 Alice was sentenced
to life in prison as a first-time
nonviolent drug offender over the next
22 years she became a prison minister
inspiring others to choose a better path
here we go
she had a big impact on that prison
population and far beyond Alice's story
underscores the disparities and
unfairness that can exist in criminal
sentencing and the need to remedy this
total injustice she's next to jail
grossest that 22 years and had expected
to be in prison for the remainder of her
life in June I commuted Alice's sense
when I saw Alice's beautiful family not
yet Ivanka Greener at the prison gates
hugging and kissing and crying and
laughing I knew I did something right
Alice is with us tonight and she is a
terrific woman
terrific Alice please what feels fake
about this is that Trump doesn't really
care about the policies big picture that
put her in prison to begin with I agree
with her being out but it shouldn't just
be because one of the Kardashians told
you to write I mean that's what's hollow
about this that Trump has not and in
fact his attorney generals have have had
the opposite view Alice thank you for
reminding us that we always have the
our to shape our own destiny thank you
very much Ellis thank you very much
really wasn't it Kim Kardashian who said
that this woman's could be released by
stories like Alice's my administration
worked closely with members of both
parties to sign the first-step Act into
law
[Applause]
this legislation reformed sentencing
laws that have wrongly and
disproportionately harmed the
african-american community the
first-step Act gives nonviolent
offenders the chance to reenter society
as productive law-abiding citizens now
states across the country are following
our lead America is a nation that
believes in Redemption we are also
joined tonight by matthew charles from
tennessee in 1996 at the age of 30
matthew was sentenced to 35 years for
selling drugs and related offenses over
the next two decades he completed more
than 30 Bible studies became a law clerk
and this is unbelievable
many of his fellow inmates now Matthew
is the very first person to be released
from prison under the first-step Act I
mean
so now Republicans want crack cocaine
dealers released from prison like is
that are we is that what we're supposed
to believe now because of Donald Trump
highlighting this guy welcome home yeah
awkward now
Republicans and Democrats must join
forces again to confront an urgent
national crisis Congress has ten days
left to pass a bill that will fund our
government protect our homeland and
secure our very dangerous southern
border now is the time for Congress to
show the world that America is committed
to ending illegal immigration and
putting the ruthless coyotes cartels
drug dealers and human traffickers out
of business
okay
as we speak large organized caravans are
on the march to the United States we
have just heard that Mexico cities in
order to remove the illegal immigrants
from I thought the caravan was a problem
months ago right before the midterms
then it's not now it is again because of
the State of the Union areas where there
is little border protection I have
ordered another three thousand seven
hundred and fifty troops to our southern
border to prepare for this tremendous
onslaught unbelievable this is a moral
issue fantasy world the lawless state of
our southern border laws a threat to the
safety security and financial well-being
of all America we have a moral duty to
create an immigration system that
protects the lives and jobs of our
citizens this includes our obligation to
the millions of immigrants living here
today who followed the rules and
respected our laws illegal immigrants
enrich our nation and strengthen our
society in countless ways
low-hanging fruit of an applause line
for her
I want people to come into our country
in the largest numbers ever from Norway
they have to come in Legally
tonight I am asking you to defend our
very dangerous southern border out of
love and devotion to our fellow citizens
and to our country no issue with a wall
better illustrates to divide between
America's working class and America's
political class than illegal immigration
wealthy politicians and donors push for
open borders while living their lives
behind walls and gates and guards I
don't know of anyone pushing for open
borders and I would love to have those
people named
meanwhile working-class Americans are
left to pay the price for mass illegal
immigration reduce jobs lower wages
overburden schools hospitals that are so
crowded you can't get in yeah it's
companies like Trump's who hire
undocumented immigrants that are that
are responsible for the wage issue with
it with undocumented immigration not the
people looking for jobs for illegal
immigration is not compassionate it is
actually very cruel I hope that Nancy
Pelosi is not going to give a single
dollar for the wall particularly after
this actually assaulted on the long
journey north smugglers use migrant
children as human pawns to exploit our
laws and gain access to our country
human traffickers and sex traffickers
take advantage of the wide open areas
between our ports of entry to smuggle
thousands of young girls and women into
the United States and to sell them into
prostitution and modern-day slavery
tens of thousands of innocent Americans
are killed by lethal drugs that cross
our border and flood into our cities
including meth heroin cocaine and
fentanyl the savage gang ms-13 now
operates in at least 20 different
American states and they almost all come
through our southern border just
yesterday an ms-13 gang member was taken
into custody for a fatal shooting on a
subway platform in New York City we are
removing these gang members by the
thousands but until we secure our border
they're going to keep streaming right
back in year after year countless
Americans are murdered by criminal
illegal aliens I've gotten to know many
wonderful angel moms and dads and
Families no one should ever have to
suffer the horrible heartache that they
have had to endure here tonight is Debra
Bissell and there it is just three weeks
ago Debra's parents Gerald and Sharon
were burglarized and shot to death in
their Reno Nevada home by an illegal
alien they were in their 80s and are
survived by four children 11
grandchildren and 20 great-grandchildren
we knew he'd do it also here tonight our
Gerald and Sharon's granddaughter
Heather and great granddaughter Madison
- Debra had their Madison please stand
few can understand your pain thank you
and thank you for being here thank you
very much
tragic and a political stunt and not
indicative that we should go to walk
I will never forget and I will fight for
the memory of Gerald and share that it
should never happen again he's already
forgotten not one more American life
should be lost because our nation failed
to control
it's very dangerous border in the last
two years our brave ice officers made
two hundred and sixty-six thousand
arrests of criminal aliens including
those charged or convicted of nearly
100,000 assaults thirty thousand sex
crimes and four thousand killings or
murders we are joined tonight by one of
those law enforcement heroes ice Special
Agent Elvin Hernandez of course
when Elvan was a boy he and his family
legally immigrated to the United States
from the Dominican Republic at the age
of eight Elvin told his dad he wanted to
become a special agent today he leads
investigations into the scourge of
international sex trafficking Elvin says
that if I couldn't anyone else noticing
from speech is starting to get a little
bit weird here I've really done my job
thanks to his work and that of his
incredible colleagues more than 300
women and girls have been rescued from
the horror of this terrible situation
and more than 1,500 sadistic traffickers
have been put behind bars
next they're going to go to the
thirty-six undocumented immigrants that
from hired at is different businesses
momentarily
we will always support the brave men and
women of law enforcement
and I pledge to you tonight that I will
never abolish our heroes from ice thank
you okay
my administration has sent to Congress a
common-sense proposal to end the crisis
on the southern border it includes
humanitarian assistance we saw the law
enforcement drug detection at our ports
closing loopholes that enable child
smuggling and and plans for a new
physical barrier or wall to secure the
vast areas between our ports of entry
and here we go again in the past most of
the people in this room voted for a wall
but the proper wall never got built I
will get it built doesn't seem like it
better
anything again
this is a smart strategic see-through
steel barrier not just a simple concrete
wall it will be deployed in the areas
identified by the border agents as
having the greatest need and these
agents will tell you where walls go up
illegal crossings go way way down you
tell you
San Diego used to have the most illegal
border crossings in our country in
response a strong security wall was put
in place this powerful barrier almost
completely ended illegal crossings the
border city of El Paso Texas used to
have extremely high rates of violent
crime one of the highest in the entire
country and considered one of our
nation's most dangerous cities now
immediately upon its building with a
powerful barrier in place El Paso is one
of the safest cities in our country none
of this stuff is true simply put walls
work and walls save lives
so let's work together compromise and
reach a deal that will truly make
America safe as we work to defend our
people safety we must also ensure our
economic resurgence continues at a rapid
pace
no one has benefited more from our
thriving economy than women who have
filled 58% of the newly created jobs
last year
yeah I really really hope that they
don't give them a penny for the wall
after this
[Applause]
you weren't supposed to do that thank
you very much thank you very much
all Americans can be proud not really
clapping for Donald I don't think he
gets it more women in the workforce than
ever before and more men and more people
out of the workforce because again the
population keeps growing
don't sit yet you know like this
and exactly one century after Congress
passed the constitutional amendment
giving women the right to vote we also
have more women serving in Congress than
at any time before it's not clear Trump
thinks that's good but he is stating a
fact
the Ivanka laqad
and Garrett is what God for the factory
okay
[Applause]
that's great I'm ready for him to rap
personally cringe-worthy and
congratulations that's great as part of
our commitment to improving opportunity
for women everywhere this Thursday we
are launching the first-ever
government-wide initiative focused on
economic empowerment for women in
developing countries to build on thank
you thank you to build on our incredible
economic success one priority is parama
skip to the last eight decades of
calamitous trade policies so bad we are
now making it clear to China that after
years of targeting our industries and
stealing our intellectual property the
theft of American jobs and wealth has
come to an end
[Applause]
therefore we recently imposed tariffs on
two hundred and fifty billion dollars of
Chinese goods which have backfired now
our treasury is receiving billions and
billions of dollars but I don't blame
China for taking that's literally okay
so we've talked about this all week he
doesn't get the difference between the
trade deficit and the budget deficit he
doesn't get it and he just did it
against travesty to happen I have great
respect for President Xi and we are now
working on a new trade deal with China
but it must include real structural
change to end unfair trade practices
reduce our chronic trade deficit and
protect American jobs III don't want to
be labor this but the Treasury gets this
tiny fraction of what are called trade
duties as a result of the tariffs and he
just doesn't seem to get that these are
two unrelated things it's bizarre
another historic trade blunder was the
catastrophe known as NAFTA I have met
the men and women of Michigan Ohio
Pennsylvania Indiana New Hampshire and
many other states whose dreams were
shattered by the signing of NAFTA for
years politicians promised them they
would renegotiate for a better deal but
no one ever tried until now our new US
Mexico Canada Agreement the u.s. MCA
will replace NAFTA and deliver for
American workers like they haven't had
delivered to for a long time I hope you
can pass the u.s. MCA into law so that
we can bring back our manufacturing jobs
and even greater numbers expand American
agriculture protect intellectual
property and ensure that more cars are
proudly stamped with our four beautiful
yeah flash to the billionaire who
said he doesn't get why people can't
just figure out where to get money
during the shutdown
tonight I am also asking you to pass the
United States reciprocal trade act so
that if another country places and
unfair tariffs on an American product we
can charge them the exact same tariff on
the exact same product that they sell to
us you already can do that without the
agreement and who decides if it's unfair
bogus both parties should be able to
unite for a great rebuilding of
America's crumbling infrastructure yes
just not by doing crony capitalist
handouts through construction
I know that Congress is eager to pass an
infrastructure bill and I am eager to
work with you or legislation to deliver
new and important infrastructure
investment including investments in the
cutting edge industries of the future as
long as the contracts go to his friends
this is a necessity
the next major priority for me and for
all of us should be to lower the cost of
health care and prescription drugs and
to protect patients with pre-existing
conditions and yet you propose nothing
to do it and neither has your party with
Willard
already as a result of my
administration's efforts in 2018 drug
prices experienced their single largest
decline in 46 years no just now
but we must do more
it's like susceptible that Americans pay
vastly more than people in other
countries for the exact same drugs often
made in the exact same place this is
wrong this is unfair and together we
will stop it unclear it's gonna happen
together as this is a problem that's not
going to be solved together Trump is
getting in the way of solving this
problem
I am asking Congress to pass legislation
that finally takes on the problem of
global freeloading and delivers fairness
and price transparency for American
patients finally so that's exactly the
type of proposal that is just vague and
meaningless and he's just saying just
pass something do something these
insurance companies and hospitals to
disclose real prices to foster
competition and bring costs way down
no force in history has done more to
advance the human condition than
American freedom in recent years along
with the countries pom poms have been
freedom to right
meaningless time and doesn't mean it
means nothing at all in recent years we
have made remarkable progress in the
fight against HIV and AIDS scientific
breakthroughs have brought a once
distant dream Within Reach
my budget will ask Democrats and
Republicans to make the needed
commitment to eliminate the HIV epidemic
in the United States within ten years we
have made incredible strides as long as
you also fund the wall
together we will defeat age in America
and beyond
[Applause]
tonight I am also asking you to join me
in another fight that all Americans can
get behind the fight against childhood
cancer okay again remember a worthy
cause Obama and Biden also talked about
this it's you know everybody wants to
fight childhood cancer joining Milania
in the gallery this evening
is a very brave ten year old girl Gracie
line every birthday
[Applause]
hi grace
every birthday since she was four grace
asked her friends to donate to st.
Jude's Children's Hospital she did not
know that one day she might be a patient
herself that's what happened last year
grace was diagnosed with brain cancer
immediately she began radiation
treatment at the same time she rallied
her community and raised more than 40
thousand dollars for the fight against
cancer extraordinary extravagant I mean
of course
but extraordinary
this does not relate from policy in any
serious man
when grace completed treatment last fall
her doctors and nurses cheered they
loved her they still loved her with
tears in their eyes as she hung up a
poster that read last day of chemo
[Applause]
thank you very much grace you are a
great inspiration to everyone in this
room thank you okay she's an inspiration
but what does this have to do with
policy childhood cancers have not seen
new therapies in decades my budget will
ask Congress for five hundred million
dollars over the next ten years to fund
this critical life-saving research to
help support working parents the time
has come to pass
school choice for Americans children
I'm also proud to be the first president
to include on my budget a plan for
nationwide paid family leave so that
every new parent has the chance to bond
with their newborn child something I
agree
Eric trumpet was completely out of it
man
there could be no greater contrast to
the beautiful image of a mother holding
her infant child then the chilling
displays our nation saw in recent days
lawmakers in New York cheered with
delight upon the passage of legislation
that would allow a baby to be ripped
from the mother's womb moments from
birth these are living feeling beautiful
babies who will never get the chance to
share their love and their dreams with
the world and then we had the case of
the governor of Virginia where he stated
he would execute a baby after birth to
defend the dignity of every person I am
asking Congress to pass legislation to
prohibit the late term abortion of
children
very very divided
House chamber
let us work together to build a culture
that cherishes I mean it's truly
shocking that we're talking about
abortion and the State of the Union
address in 2019 it's it's absolutely
insane super uniting issue right
[Applause]
you can look at pens he loves it
and let us reaffirm a fundamental truth
all children born and unborn are made in
the holy image of God the final part of
my agenda is to protect American
security over the last two years we have
begun to fully rebuild the United States
military with rebuild it's been the
biggest for who knows how long now last
year and 716 billion dollars this year
we are also getting other nations to pay
their fair share
for years the United States was being
treated very unfairly by friends of ours
members of NATO but now we have secured
over the last couple of years more than
100 billion dollars of increase in
defense spending from our NATO allies
this is so backwards remember Trump's
claim was they're not paying their fair
share because they're not paying what
they committed to but of course they
didn't commit to it but now Trump is
touting as a victory the fact that he's
gotten vague commitments which weren't
real from the beginning right I mean
it's just a circle a state-of-the-art
missile defense system under my
administration we will never apologize
for advancing America's interests for
example decades ago the United States
entered into a treaty with Russia in
which we agreed to limit and reduce our
missile capability yes we did well we
followed the agreement and the rules to
the letter Russia repeatedly violated
its terms it's been going on for many
years that is why I announced that the
United States is officially withdrawing
from the intermediate-range nuclear
forces treaty or INF treaty that's
exactly right
Russia can now go back to full steam
ahead
clapping for this is insane we really
have no choice
perhaps we can negotiate a different
agreement adding China and others or
perhaps we can't in which case we will
out spend and out-innovate all others by
far what in what a uniting and inspiring
statement
as part of a bold new diplomacy we
continue our historic push for peace on
the Korean Peninsula our hostages have
come home nuclear testing has stopped
and there has not been a missile launch
in more than 15 months yeah nuclear
testing is not stopped I mean that
they're ramping up this is incredibly
demonstrably untrue we would right now
in my opinion be in a major war with
North Korea that is addressed much work
remains to be done but my relationship
with Kim jong-un is a good one
chairman Kim and I will meet again on
February 27th and 28th in Vietnam muted
applause personally to the bastard
two weeks ago the United States
officially recognized the legitimate
government of Venezuela and its new
president
we stand with the Venezuelan people in
their noble quest for freedom and we
condemned the brutality of the Maduro
regime Maduro socialist policies have
turned that nation from being the
wealthiest in South America into a state
of abject poverty and despair
here in the United States we are alarmed
by the new calls to adopt socialism in
our country no one's calling for that
America was founded on liberty and
independence and not government coercion
domination and control we are born free
and we will stay free red herring no
one's calling for socialism like five
people are
[Applause]
tonight we renew our resolve that
America will never be a socialist
country this is one of the most
pointless moments in any State of the
Union address there is no chance that
there is any serious progress towards
actual socialism being made anytime soon
it's a red herring it's a distraction it
is pointless but it probably works one
of the most complex set of challenges we
face and have for many years is in the
Middle East
our approach is based on principle
realism not discredited theories that
have failed for decades to yield
progress for this reason my
administration recognized the true
capital of Israel and proudly opened the
American Embassy in Jersey huge mistake
not uniting but dividing was a mistaken
policy was a bad idea and if he's trying
to unite people why he would even bring
it up during a State of the Union
address I couldn't tell our brave troops
have now been fighting in the Middle
East for almost 19 years in Afghanistan
and Iraq nearly 7,000 American heroes
have given their lives more than 52,000
Americans have been badly wounded
we have spent more than seven trillion
dollars in fighting wars in the Middle
East as a candidate for president I
loudly pledged a new approach great
nations do not fight endless wars
okay you can agree on
when I took office Isis controlled more
than 20,000 square miles in Iraq and
Syria just two years ago today we have
liberated virtually all of the territory
from the grip of these blood thirsty
monsters now as we work with our allies
to destroy the remnants of Isis it is
time to give up brave warriors in Syria
a warm welcome home I have also
accelerated our negotiations to reach if
possible a political settlement in
Afghanistan the opposing side is also
very happy to be negotiating our troops
have fought with unmatched valor and
thanks to their bravery we are now able
to pursue a possible political solution
to this long and bloody conflict Trump
has no idea what he's talking about here
literally no I he could not go in-depth
on any of what he's talking about here
he's literally just reading something
Stephen Miller wrote for
in Afghanistan my administration is
holding constructive talks with a number
of Afghan groups including the Taliban
as we make progress in these
negotiations we will be able to reduce
our troops presence and focus on counter
terrorism and we will indeed focus on
counter terrorism we do not know whether
we'll achieve an agreement but we do
know that after two decades of war the
hour has come to at least try for peace
and the other side would like to do the
same thing it's time
[Applause]
above all friend and foe alike was never
doubt this nation's power and will to
defend our people eighteen years ago
violent terrorists attacked the USS Cole
and last month American forces killed
one of the leaders of that attack
[Applause]
we are honored to be joined tonight by
Tom Whibley whose son Navy Seaman Craig
Whibley was one of the 17 sailors we
tragically lost Tom we vowed to always
remember the heroes of the USS Cole
look at the clock I mean this is barely
even the first time a body is political
my administration has acted decisively
to confront the world's leading state
sponsor of Terror the radical regime in
Iran it is a radical regime they say had
bad things to ensure this corrupt
dictatorship never acquires nuclear
weapons I withdrew the United States
from the disastrous Iran nuclear deal
[Applause]
and last fall we put in place the
toughest sanctions ever imposed by us on
a country yeah
disaster right I mean Iran didn't
violate the deal and then the u.s. backs
out it just kills our credibility it's
pathetic and embarrassing America and
threatens genocide against the Jewish
people
[Applause]
Nancy Pelosi looks like she's just
reviewing her electrical bill
we must never ignore the vile poison of
anti-semitism or those who spread its
venomous Creed with one voice we must
confront this hatred anywhere and
everywhere it occurs just months ago
eleven Jewish Americans were viciously
murdered in an anti-semitic attack some
negative life synagogue in Pittsburgh
SWAT officer Timothy Matson raced into
the gunfire and was shot seven times
chasing down the killer and he was very
successful Timothy has just had his 12th
surgery and he's going in for many more
but he made the trip to be here with us
tonight
officer Matson please
[Applause]
thank you we are forever grateful thank
you very much sound sincere tonight we
are also joined by Pittsburgh survive
Judah salmon he arrived at the synagogue
as the massacre began but not only did
Judah narrowly escaped death last fall
more than seven decades ago he narrowly
survived the Nazi concentration camps
today is Judas 81st birthday this guy's
story I feel is incredible I'm not sure
how many people are familiar with it but
it unbelievable
oh dear there is nothing more awkward
than Donald Trump reacting
[Applause]
they wouldn't do that for me Judith
Judis says he can still remember the
exact moment nearly 75 years ago after
10 months in a concentration camp when
he and his family were put on a train
and told they were going to another camp
suddenly everything about Judas
Annette's story is incredible and seeing
Donald Trump turn it into a political
prop is truly disgusting Judy's family
braced for the absolute worse than his
father cried out with joy
it's the Americans it's the Americans
[Music]
thank you a second Holocaust survivor
who was here tonight
Joshua Kaufman was a prisoner at Dachau
he remembers watching through a hole in
the wall of a cattle car as American
soldiers rolled in with tanks to meet
Joshua Lee calls the American soldiers
were proof that God exists and they came
down from the sky they came down from
heaven I began this evening to see these
stories turned into these political
props for Donald Trump who has coalesced
anti-semitism and white nationalism is
one of the most disgusting things in a
long time in a State of the Union
address the beaches of Normandy Herman
was one of the American soldiers who
helped liberate Dachau
[Applause]
he was one of the Americans who helped
rescue Joshua from that hell on earth
almost 75 years later Herrmann and
Joshua are both together in the gallery
tonight seated side by side here in the
home of American freedom Herrmann and
Joshua your presence this evening is
very much appreciated thank you very
much
one of the most disgusting displays of
everything that you could possibly
imagine would would go wrong at a trump
State of the Union
what can we even say sicken me I see
people in the tracks and a lot of people
it is sickening
thank you when American soldiers said
that beneath the dark skies over the
English Channel in the early hours of
d-day 1944 they were just young men of
eighteen and nineteen hurtling on
fragile landing craft toward the most
momentous battle in the history of war
they did not know if they would survive
the hour they did not know if they would
grow old but they knew that America had
to prevail their cause was this nation
and generations yet unborn why did they
do it they did it for America they did
it for us everything that has come since
our triumph over communism our giant
leaps of science and discovery our
unrivaled progress towards equality and
justice all of it is possible thanks to
the blood and tears and courage and
vision of the Americans who came before
think of this Capitol think of this very
chamber where lawmakers before you voted
to end slavery to build the railroads
and the highways and defeat fascism to
secure civil rights
and to face down evil empires here
tonight we have legislators from across
this magnificent republic you have come
from the rocky shores of Maine and the
volcanic Peaks of Hawaii from the snowy
woods of Wisconsin and the red deserts
of Arizona from the green farms of
Kentucky and the golden beaches of
California together we represent the
most extraordinary nation in all of
history what will we do with this moment
how will we be remembered I ask the men
and women of this Congress look at the
opportunities before us our most
thrilling achievements are still ahead
our most exciting journeys still await
our biggest victories are still to come
and please stop the investigation we
have not yet begun to dream we must
choose whether we are defined by our
differences or whether we dare to
transcend them we must choose whether we
squander our great inheritance or
whether we proudly declare that we are
Americans we do the incredible we defy
the impossible we conquer the unknown
this is the time to reignite the
American imagination this is the time to
search for the tallest summit and set
our sights
on the brightest star wrap it up this is
the time to rekindle the bonds of love
and loyalty and memory that link us
together as citizens as neighbors as
Patriots this is our future our fate and
our choice to make I am asking you to
choose greatness
no matter the trials we face no matter
the challenges to come we must go
forward together we must keep America
first in our hearts we must keep freedom
alive in our souls and we must always
keep faith in America's destiny that one
nation under God must be the hope and
the promise and the light and the glory
among all the nations of the world thank
you god bless you and God bless america
thank you meaningless political
platitudes delivered poorly I think is
the way that I would sort of sum up this
State of the Union address a
particularly poorly delivered speech
touted as uniting but talked about
abortion and demanded money for the wall
and made political props out of people
who quite frankly don't deserve it and
it's really a disturbing speech in a way
that no recent State of the Union
address certainly none by President
Obama nor even george w bush have
approached a very very long speech
partially because of Donald Trump's
delivery partially because of the
applause brakes partially because it was
just endless in many many ways I will
consider opening the phone lines if
people want to chime in we are accepting
new members at join Pakman
dot-com as I mentioned it was my 35th
birthday over the weekend so what better
thing to do than to offer a $35 discount
off of our $60 memberships with the code
save 35 if we get just a couple more new
members I will open up the phone lines
momentarily at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 if
people want to chime in an
extraordinarily bizarre speech getting
endless endless texts here with
different views about what what we saw
to call it a uniting speech as it was
billed I don't think anybody can argue
is what took place to call it a speech
that maybe was in some way effective for
Trump's base I think you maybe have a
point there I I think that that would be
the strongest case the the strongest
case that could be made and
disappointing there will be plenty of
time for the policy analysis and so much
else that that needs to be discussed and
I just I just don't even know where to
go let's see if I can okay let's see if
we can get set up now to take calls from
people I will thank a bunch of the new
members who have signed up 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 I will open up the phone lines let
me thank Carlos Chavez Carlos Soto Kevin
carpenter Lee Lim dusty herd Joanna our
tone Donna molar Linda Sharpe Stewart
hazard Daniel Johnson
Ian Nelson Carter link Jillian plaster
Prakash Kumar Brandon Roach and Paul
Flores and so many different people who
have signed up while we wet we have been
watching Donald Trump deliver truly one
of the most bizarre State of the Union
addresses that that I can recall in
length and its use of political props in
just about every way so let's see what's
on people's minds at 6 1
eight-30 4750 i will mention that we are
we still have this coupon code going if
you appreciate the livestreams if you
want more live streams sign up for a
membership at join pakman.com it's our
primary source of funding there's a
coupon code available to you save 35 if
you apply that coupon code to the $60 a
year membership where it says coupon
code on the second page of the sign up 6
you will save $35 off of the $60
membership which is a very very exciting
thing ok so let me get set up here with
our phone system which is very very
quickly blowing up there are actually so
many people calling in that I'm having
trouble getting connected myself let's
see if we can get I need to get
connected to the system or we're not
going to be able to take any phone calls
let's see what we can do here 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 momentarily I should be able to
take phone calls let's see if I can make
it happen
yeah there is uh our phone system is
being completely overwhelmed and I am
actually having trouble calling in
myself which is not a good problem to
have
Wow okay I'm going to reset the phone
system real quick I apologize but this
is going to probably disconnect
everybody who has called in and you may
have to call back in but let me see I am
trying to get the phone system up and
running so many people are trying to
call in at once that the system is being
overwhelmed okay let's give it another
shot at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 alright I've
been able to get connected this time
let's see if we can make it all happen
ok I think it's working at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 let's give it a shot let's go to
our caller from the 5 4 1 area code
caller from 5 4 1 is it working can you
hear me can we hear you
5 4 1 are you there 5 4 1 is gone
alright let's try our caller from the 9
to 9 area code caller from 9 to 9 are
you there hi hey 9 to 9 what's going on
hi david obie kind of a show
i was just wondering what are you
expecting from like the democratic
response to the State of the Union I'm
expecting that there will be some
connection to the real world represented
I'm expecting hopefully some particular
rebuttals I mean many many lies were
told by Donald Trump during the speech
related to jobs numbers related to the
characterization of trade deals and so
many different things I mean I have
copious notes here pages of notes here
so I hope that they introduce some
connection to reality and we can hear
the actual facts but as you know you
know the ratings for the rebuttal are
always far lower than the speech itself
and the damage may have been done and
just one last thing
how do you feel about Bernie Sanders
doing a separate
response from the Democrats I want to
hear from Bernie and his perspective is
different so I I want to hear from
Bernie myself all right thank you how
much all right thank you six one seven
eight three zero 47 50 let's go to our
caller from the 7/7 for area code 774 go
ahead that me I'm actually in Sarasota
well I don't know where you are but are
your 774 so yeah that's you yeah I think
that advisors awesome decided to make
this go long - not only bite into the
Democrat time but also he wants to eat
personally say that he's had the longest
state-of-the-union ever I really believe
that you know what it did that's not
nearly the craziest thing I've heard I
do think that this was timed this was
designed to go long for a number of
different reasons yeah I mean I can't
disagree with you okay all right seems
like we lost that caller maybe he was
just stunned by my agreement let's go to
the 978 area code and is 958 Boston area
yeah hey what's going on hey hey David
I'm yeah I'm from Boston the area my
question is I was thinking about this do
you think it's good for Bernie and aost
to kind of just avoid the whole
Venezuela topic right now because they'd
just be smeared with the whole socialism
thing if they said oh don't invade
Venezuela um listen here's the thing
about Venezuela if you I don't know if
you've seen any of the clips I've done
about it but if you you basically
everybody is being couched as either a
socialist or a neocon imperialist and
I'm trying to actually you know explain
what's what's going on there as I see it
and explain that I'm against
intervention but I'm against Maduro and
I need to you know sanctions have not
been solely responsible for the downfall
because actually there haven't really
been that many economic sanctions up
until more recently I think that what
you're right about is that the Venezuela
topic is very very toxic
now and I don't know that there's
political upside for them but these are
you know prominent elected officials
they also can't really ignore it
practically speaking yeah that's true
yeah you know also I think that like
saying um we should be more Social
Democrats rather than not being in favor
of social democracy rather than
socialism it's a better way who kept
people on our side well it's better if
that's what you believe that's what I
believe you know presumably there are
actual socialists who would disagree
with you but we're getting a bad
connection so I'm gonna let you go but I
really appreciate the phone call we're
hearing from whoever wants to chime in
at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's go to the 8 5
8 area code caller from 8 5 8 what's
going on David hey what's going on yeah
I was gonna ask you like what that whole
social stick it's just been kind of
force and it was kind of like I don't
know it just seemed like it was like red
meat you like the idiots in the crowd
yeah people if people missed what what
we're talking about here there was this
moment where Trump just started talking
about socialism's bad and we've got a
fight against socialism and you we need
to prevent a socialist takeover which is
it's it's just pointless from actual
talking about ideas perspective but it's
potentially really effective red meat
because there's no risk that the United
States is about to become a socialist
country there's barely any actual
socialists in the United States we're
basically talking about a debate between
less regulated capitalism and more
regulated capitalism and it was bizarre
to see him just start insulting
socialism but maybe that's effective for
his base maybe his base likes to see
that stuff yeah I mean yeah we need help
ok thanks David yeah I don't know any
other way to put it
thanks to Cynthia Figueroa and Daniel
bailan and Deborah Arden who have just
signed up using the membership special
that you see on your screen
let's go to the 703 area code 703 is
Virginia right I love hey what's going
on in Virginia today
well yeah being twenty minutes away from
the government yeah just politics
constantly in the news here and it's
really interesting to me how he didn't
talk about any her he didn't come close
to declaring a national emergency or
hitting at that at all correct which I
thought he might he not and just kind of
strike fear in the Democrats to try and
make them come to the table and provide
some money for border security I don't
even know that it would work though I
mean if I'm if I'm Nancy Pelosi right
now and I think Trump is getting so
belligerent about border wall funding
that he might declare a national
emergency I don't know that that gets me
to give him money for the wall I think
that gets me to hold even firmer and say
that's his political risk to take yeah I
mean that's just a problem though it's
probably going to be another government
shutdown in ten eleven days then
everybody here is gonna be furloughed
laid off where it could just keep we can
just at least here in the DC area
speaking for me what I'm seeing from
people government workers we just can't
have that again so I mean I hope you
just Trump just quit I know he's
probably not going to do that yeah but
if he moves on to some of the other
issues he talked about that could
actually bipartisan I forgot
specifically but he was talking about
childhood cancer and all these other
things that aren't so polarizing that
means those are those aren't even those
are barely political issues because
everybody just agrees
you know like who doesn't want to cure
cancer it's a question of how do we do
it what money do do we devote to it the
speech was billed as it was going to be
uniting but he talked about abortion
build the wall and made some of the most
disgusting political props I've ever
seen out of people in the crowd like the
the I agree with you that another
shutdown would be a disaster but Nancy
Pelosi I don't think should give him a
penny for his wall yeah I mean I agree
there it's just it's probably gonna be
another shutdown and the other thing was
in terms of yeah with the other holders
point
about socialism thing to me it just
seems like the older Democrats who are
less in I mean young kids these days and
the younger generations are favoring
more and more more social democratic
policies may just ghost show how I touch
the older Democrats who think some kind
of communist regime or socialist
sensation is going to just transform the
US and to Venezuela
really striking to me how scared they're
getting just trying to defend this
capitalist system that has isn't working
for a lot of people yeah and I think the
other important thing to remember is
that work that there's no there's no
great clamoring for actual socialism
right so it's it's sort of a false enemy
but that's the way it's been for a
really long time with many people in the
United States yeah it's interesting
all right thanks David yep thanks for
the call really appreciate it okay let's
see who's on the phones from the four
eight zero area code which i think is
that's Arizona right yes it is it's
miles um so oh my god first of all that
stated Union I I'm at a loss for words
to be honest which is shocking because
you usually shot out of the cannon miles
I calm in most situation I guess if I
had to I mean what do we I guess at this
point you don't even you may not know
but what was the worst part about that
to me it was when he played coy with the
Holocaust survivors yeah I was gonna me
the worst part was the Holocaust
survivor moment and I mean it's so you
know the we're talking about we're
talking about incredible stories we're
talking about tragic stories we're
talking about stories of human
achievement and perseverance and
inspiration and all of this different
stuff but it was a prop to make some
kind of political point which was so
poorly delivered by Trump that I don't
even know what it was it was just
here's holic people associated with the
Holocaust it was it was absolutely
disgusting that for me was the low point
yeah III don't know what was worse that
or way back right after tree of life
what might
get that disgraced Jew for Jesus guy I
don't even know at this point I don't
even know what was worse yeah maybe but
uh yeah I guess I'll I guess one other
thing how how does you said that this is
so much worse than even like a bush or
Obama like what I mean that that stated
okay listen I mean I get it he's doing
stuff that he thinks his base will like
and maybe it was effective but from the
point of view of the speech as a speech
in terms of having a coherent beginning
middle and end and sort of crescendoing
and building it to policy proposals in a
way that fits into the narrative that
he's creating and yet I mean it was a
disastrous speech in terms of evaluating
the speech it was also riddled with lies
it used political props seemingly
aimlessly I mean it was an absolute
disaster yeah all right good talk man
okay miles I got a run but good to hear
from you let's go to let's see where are
we going to go next why don't we go so
many people holding it's hard to even
know let's go to the five eight five
area code because five eight five
anytime I see five eight five it could
be the eggman because I think that's
like upstate New York or the Eggman's
from whoa yeah that's you I'm guessing
you're not the Eggman um so probably the
most surprising thing on the speech was
how he'd argue with the previous person
who said that the Holocaust survivor he
pointed to the Holocaust survivor and
the reason I had surprised me so much
was because he pretty much pointed at
him and said here give me pity points
and that maybe time I get directly was
saying that yeah but it was kind of like
that was so shocking to me speech yeah
but when he said we defeated communism
and we defeated fascism I think that
he's a bit of a fascist myself so what
do you think he's fascistic I mean he
has authoritarian tendencies doll it's
all authoritarian leaders that appeal to
him he when he heard that the Chinese
made it so that he could get reelected
indefinitely he said maybe we would try
that sometime he doesn't like freedom of
the press he you know so yeah I mean the
guy has authoritarian tendencies and you
can be fascistic without being a fascist
or without having a system of fascism as
we've talked about with a number of
academic experts on the subject I think
you're right all right well thank you
okay thank you appreciate the call all
right let's try the whatare there's
something weird we have a caller that is
just from the number one that's just I
mean I'm so curious about that that I'm
going to go to it because it could be
really weird caller from just the phone
number one you do would you even know
who that is I'm guessing it's a glitch
of some kind
hi there to hear me yeah how did you
know you were the caller calling from
phone number one because right now
there's a weird power fault and I'm
using an online phone oh all right well
it's a weird weird service I don't know
what I'm using alright what's going on
so I guess it's just an inquiry about
your commentary so I guess what I think
is Trump constantly lies right yep so
his supporters don't really care when he
lies because they'll take it you'll just
take everything he says at face value
everyone who disagrees with him no he
lot knows he lies and I mean no one's
really gonna come over to his side so do
you think there's still a purpose to the
commentaries you provide alongside is
his speeches nope there's absolutely no
purpose whatsoever to the commentary I
provide unfortunately you don't think so
no I'm kidding around listen here's the
one rare you know where I disagree with
you some of his supporters believe
everything he says
others know that he's lying but they
write it off by using this phrase listen
they all lie but I at least think Trump
has the right idea so it's not that
everybody just believes him they just
excuse the line right okay thank you for
the call yeah great to hear from you
okay let's go to our next caller from
the let's go to the 732 area
who's there from 7-3 - is that me
it is you this is Val and even though
it's seven three two I'm calling from
Massachusetts
alright we're on time fan of your show
Agawam okay you know Agawam interesting
fact about Agawam is that Agawam has the
first zip code of the country zero one
zero zero one and i don't know why that
would ever be useful to anyone but
that's it it is a fun fact though isn't
it it is anyway I just want to let you
know two things number one I love it
when you say that people are shot out of
a cannon okay I'm not sure where you got
that from but I love it okay anyway the
other question I had was that did you
notice that the women that were all
wearing weight obviously they were
shouting USA they were like joining in
with the USA chanting I thought that was
a little bit I don't know if they were
trying to mock no what was your take on
that they were trying to take ownership
of it right that because they chanted if
I recall correctly the the contingent of
women dressed in white who are the I
believe it's all new first-year elected
female elected officials and I think
that they're all Democrats although I'm
not 100 after the idea was when Trump
started talking about record number of
women etc etc they started chanting USA
to sort of say this is what the USA is
and should be I think that was they were
sort of trying to take ownership of it
and make the USA chant their own okay
that sounds like a good take on it I
like that no keep up the great work
okay thank you very much appreciate the
call all right take care take care bye
great to hear from people from the first
home of the David Pakman show Western
Massachusetts let's go to the 202 area
code the going right to the belly of the
beast someone who might be in DC I guess
at least possibly no I'm actually in
Vermont but I am from DC okay fair
enough you can still be on the show
thanks I have a question not related to
pie
one question related to politics and
another request not related to politics
okay first do you think Andrew yang has
a legitimate shot at the presidency
because a lot of people like Oh his
whatever him wanting to give out a
universal basic income that's just gonna
make inflation skyrocket and people
aren't going to take him seriously and
some people are skeptical with the robot
revolution which his whole campaign is
based around based and I know you've
endured I think you've interviewed him
yes and so do you think he has a
legitimate shot at the presidency listen
I think it's too early to tell right now
there are so many candidates and he is
polling like one point something percent
in Iowa which is more than zero he has
run the numbers and the logic that he's
presenting is that based on the number
of people who actually participate in
the Iowa caucuses he can get a plurality
of the votes if you have the number of
candidates that you currently have with
something like 30 or 40 thousand votes I
think it is which is a reasonable number
for almost anyone who has a campaign
infrastructure so I think that Iowa is
going to be telling let's see how he
does in Iowa and then go from there but
I do think that he has a good
organization he is a numbers guy
self-described he says he's the opposite
of Trump because he's an Asian guy who
likes math that's a quote from my
interview with him last week so he
understands exactly what the path would
be to getting some had making headway in
the Iowa caucuses and then we'll see
what happens after that
I like his platform quite a bit and you
know putting all electability questions
aside he's he's in my top three right
now yeah and another comment about entry
and before I get to my question that's
not about politics okay is that he's
actually a business success story unlike
Donald Trump like I brought up Larry
Hogan last time who they're both
business success stories Larry Hogan and
Andrew yang so he could use that against
Trump in a general election debate
indeed yeah second question I watch so I
am a musician and I watch your videos
with my rock band drummer on expert
village and I have a question for you
who is your favorite
drummer I don't have a favorite drummer
but people I like include Steve Gadd and
Vinnie Colaiuta I like Billy Joel used
to have this drummer Liberty DeVito who
I like there's just so many Carter
Beauford from Dave Matthews Band is
great it really depends on the style but
I mean there's just dozens and dozens of
drummers that I like all right thank you
and have a great day okay you too great
to hear from folks in Vermont let's go
to the eight one five area code eight
one five has been holding on for a while
what's going on hey my my paintings I
see that they're making is that the
Republicans are making it difficult with
the tax returns and I was reading on
Twitter that some people are speculating
that they might not comply with
subpoenas yep how far do you see that
going you see arrest warrants being
issued if they don't just how far do you
see that issue going so this is a good
question we're actually going to cover
it extensively on tomorrow's show
now that Democrats control the house
there's the very real possibility of
subpoenas of Donald Trump's tax returns
Donald Trump has enlisted a team at the
Treasury of course headed up by Steven
minuchin his Treasury Secretary to
basically create a two-pronged approach
for keeping the tax returns away from
Democrats the first one is to argue that
even though Democrats shouldn't leak
Trump's tax returns that they are going
to and so they shouldn't be released to
Democrats to begin with the second
strategy is basically to just put in
legal challenges and unfortunately I
think that that could work because they
can without straight up rejecting the
subpoena requests they can tie it up in
court with all sorts of arcane legal
arguments and they can just run the
clock out and unfortunately that might
actually work okay yeah no problem
thanks for calling in okay let's see
who's on let's go back to the 774 area
code which could be happy' of
massachusetts caller yeah that's me
again
good so um
yes we talked to two seconds on it and I
got cut off
why do you think they were trying to
make this speech go long what is the
political strategy there I say two ideas
one idea is that by making it go long
you are pushing the Democratic response
later and later out closer to being out
of prime time that's one idea the other
idea is just because Trump likes to hear
himself talk and he wanted to be out
there for a while okay okay now I don't
know that we have to look too deep on
that one yet by the way the third one is
just that Trump delivered the speech way
more slowly than was anticipated I think
he does that with this feeling that it's
gravitas yeah gravitas means I know what
I'm talking about
yep sniffing the applause thing is Italy
slowed it way down yeah okay good thank
you for the call appreciate it we may
delve into that more tomorrow okay let's
go to the 276 area code caller from 276
who's there
hey David this is Keith Jones
I'm calling from more in South West
Virginia from a town called Bristol okay
yeah I guess I kind of switched between
your stream and the Young Turks is
stream throughout the whole speech and I
just noticed you know Trump just seemed
like he was on ambien the whole spin she
just talked so slow it was just so hard
to pay attention but uh have one they're
both both questions are kind of short do
you think that like all the Democrats
that will be running for to challenge
Trump of 2020 do you think that they'll
be able to weaponize his that one area
this feature he talked about you know
the synagogue's shooting hit
Pennsylvania but he didn't really hurt
ooh
[Music]
right-wing terrorists that kind of went
in there and just shot it up because it
was a synagogue or do you think that you
know they'll have a lot more important
things to attack Trump for no but but
here's the thing by the time Democrats
who are running for 2020 actually are in
the position of attacking Trump rather
than running against each other that the
fact that that's how Trump handled that
moment of the speech is going to be sort
of distant a distant memory yeah I
figured so there's just one of those
little things of like art to me because
jank on The Young Turks stream was just
constantly begging Chum to be like you
know are you gonna denounce the
right-wing terrorism and I was like no
there was no there was no data that that
was going to happen and then a second
other smaller question is the really
last the last election in 2016 was kind
of the first one I'm only 24 years old
so the the 2016 election was the one I
really like paid attention to from you
know the primary all the way up to the
general and saying 17 Republicans on you
know one stage trying to fight for two
seconds of attention do you think that
even if this Democratic field swells to
even that big or even bigger how do you
think that you know somebody like Bernie
Sanders or Tulsi or whatever kind of
progressive voice what do you think
they're going to have to do to stand out
amongst all these corporatist Democrats
well it's going to depend on who you're
talking about
I think medicare-for-all is going to be
a litmus test and we've already seen
Kamala Harris sort of soften from the
original position of it's got to be
Medicare for all so I think that whether
they hold steady or or sort of waiver on
Medicare for all it could be a
distinguishing factor but I actually
think it's sort of a little too early to
tell what the dividing lines are going
to be at this point in time because a
lot of it is going to be determined by
number one what's going on with the
economy at the time number two as the
race keeps going because the next six
months we could
either have a continuation of what we've
seen economically or a reversal that
that would impact the conversation the
narrative around Trump's criminality is
probably going to in fact impact the
tone and tenor of the race so I think
it's early but I do think that
medicare-for-all is going to be a big
factor yeah definitely I also think a
lot of those corporate Democrats you
know they're they're not going to have
you know the not really the ability but
the the conviction that somebody like
Bernie Sanders or even they're
definitely Bernie but even somebody like
tulsi or Elizabeth Warren will have to
you know convey that message to the
American people watching that you know
I'm definitely for this and I will not
you know turn my back the next day or
you know talk it walk it back in anyway
yeah I'm not so sure about Tulsi I mean
I did a segment today I've crossed Tulsi
off my list and I'm that it's it's not
for me so I don't I'm gonna sort of be
following her a little bit less closely
now that I've sort of decided that
that's not somebody that I can support
but I think you're completely right that
Bernie would be Bernie's not even
running yet by the way Bernie would be
at the top of the list to sort of just
hold steady and not moderate his
positions because of political public
pressure of any kind appreciate the call
thank you so much for calling I got a
run now we've taken a bunch of calls
we've done a lot of stuff I appreciate
everybody who called in I'm sorry I
can't get to all of the calls but I will
stream again and I will take calls again
as well